[Music]
in don't worry be happy news lately
submitted by Harvey not the hurricane a
recent study suggests you don't need
positive emotions to be happy how does
it work positive emotions happy I
thought happy was a positive motion so
who did you eat that that's a psychopath
and a serial killer right there yeah I
have my gun will [ __ ] shoot people
I'm happy as well that's true so what
they did is they got two thousand three
hundred and twenty four people from
eight different countries so from the US
Brazil China Germany Ghana Israel Poland
and Singapore and they gave them surveys
to fill out on either paper or online
and first they had to rank their desired
emotions and indicate how often they
wanted to experience those emotions and
then they spent five minutes playing
emotionally neural word games to kind of
like cleanse the mental palate and
finally they ended up reporting how
often they felt those same emotions in
their daily lives on a one to five scale
and so what they found out is that a lot
of people prize high arousal Pleasant
state like excitement and so a lot of
people will rather have excitement
rather than low activation like be more
nation's morality one yet or like
excited to go to vacation or excited to
receive a gift or something like
something that gives you like that high
arousal yeah I've been waiting for this
movie to come out and then you go watch
it yeah I want to say receive a gift
like you can't wait like you have that
boyish look how you do I'd love to see
you see a couple of gifts that bring it
on Christmas time alright
no he doesn't care I know I seen him get
giddy yeah yeah yeah he does we should
give him a Nintendo 64 the script Oh see
how he reacts have you have you seen the
way he reacts when when he connects with
a person that enjoys the same food and
they talk about
present that is a fresh shift of
friendship is a present yes
no not really yeah see it
nah dude he kept talking about the magic
the you're on your own forever right
feels so excited and I was like calling
in a boyfriend for his birthday I got it
for him the package came in on like
guess what I got you and then I told him
and then he was like okay cooling down
on that someone appreciate maybe is
already expecting any give it to him in
his mind so he just no I told you when
they get go I don't I don't I don't care
for presents really see exactly you
doesn't care for presents but I can
understand the plight of a child when
you know when they received is a child
no but yet anyway so this study they're
saying that so so people rather have
like high arousal Pleasant states like
excitement and other people like low
activation Pleasant emotions like
calmness so then like different people
rated different things but pretty much
what it boils down to is that if you
want to be happy just look at which
feelings or emotions that you want to
feel and then if you feel those emotions
and that's what's going to lead to
happiness for example other people they
rated anger hatred and contempt as one
of like the desired emotions that they
want to feel like that's weird wait to
be a I actually love being angry I mean
it it nothing inspires me more than like
my white-hot hatred in my heart that I
have
seriously like like I get passionate
about things and then I start to zero in
on like why I hate them and then you
know I'm gonna change the world its age
it's yeah it's idea generating you know
you know you know my idea behind anger
is actually not the for me at least then
I don't know about you but for me I like
being angry but not because of for the
sake of being angry I like being angry
because I want to be right I like being
right and usually when you're angry it's
because you're in a debate you're like
you have a problem with something it's
argumentative and so you want to be
right and I think is that is that the
same for you like no no not even close
not even close never mind
well no it's nothing for me it's not
about being right because I don't know I
don't think I'm right all the time I'm
not one of those guys I just I love
knowing what I don't know but that's not
only related to this for me it's just
about like it's like what pisses me the
[ __ ] off and how can I use this or how
can i how can I deal with this it gives
you that drive so when when I'm pissed
off I'm like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and then
I'll go into editing like all right from
now I'm really focused and I can push
really hard on what I want to do because
all right so they give you that drive
layout a spite right we're getting
revenge like you we love that I have
anger problems I think I need to tone it
down is my thing I I think it disables
me for days so that's not a demotion
yeah I mean like once my angers just
triggered like it I feel like paralyzed
because I'm just so mad and I'm like the
only thing I can do is work out and in
if there's humans around me I might take
it or take it out on them or like I
might I might just I just I feel like
cussing at you one day or I don't know
it's just weird I know a lot of people
use that negative energy and you use it
for inspiration like yes this is wrong
in the world we need to save it or do
something right my mind goes to this is
the reason why we need to have genocides
it goes it goes they're like man I
remember one time I got myself really
worked out like worked up because I was
taking a shower and I just somehow
thought like these guys were gonna grab
me one day and throw me in the van and
kidnap me what guys huh Oh guys you're
in the shower
but guys these guys that if I go travel
to it to like Southeast Asia because I
like to travel and if I go there like
they're gonna see that I'm a tourist and
then they're gonna grab me up and throw
me in the van so I was like in my mind I
started like no I'm gonna grab him by
the [ __ ] neck and slam him against
the wall and then before I knew it I was
like outside my shower doing karate
and I was like wet as [ __ ] and I'm like
wow how did I get outside here like wait
which shower was yeah you have anger
problems for yeah my own house I was
just showering and then like come
through yeah I got into like no if that
happens I'm gonna grab this comment I'm
gonna do that and I got out of the
shower cuz I was like the van door wall
turn it in mind
yeah and I'm out so I'm outside I'm like
duh and I'm like oh [ __ ] what the hell
I'll make it outside the bathroom where
did you he was out in his neighborhood
[Laughter]
yeah that's really weird honestly hey I
have to keep it down too because
sometimes like what's in here comes
outside like a bum you know how like
went bum start since knocking through
the valve [ __ ] you want my
[ __ ] money and she's like and then
just would be another room like why so
for you anger is a desired emotion cuz
you enjoy yeah I love it no I don't want
anyone to take my anger away it's cuz
it's please take mine you could have
mine please cuz I don't know what I
would do if my rage was gone I don't
know what I would do
I really don't oh is that what drives
you as a comedian yeah for sure yeah
interests you I have to be it has its
targeted anger at whatever it is what's
the emotion that you feel that you don't
like feeling feeling I like feeling a
lot of yeah maybe love not know man I
don't know I don't think there's any
emotions I don't want to feel I guess
sorry for myself it's one of them for
sure I never want to feel sorry for
myself and I never want to feel censored
by myself because of somebody else well
like you're gonna I guess oh oh
no I'll never do that it's like holding
in a fart right yeah it's not healthy
for anybody yeah I mean I think an
emotion that I try to avoid is that
happy cry emotion which is funny because
a lot of people that watch our Channel
they feel that emotion all the time
that's my favorite emotion I hate that
emotion I hate that lump in my throat of
like it isn't like happy feeling I don't
know why I think growing up I would
obviously a lot of movies that would
make me have that like that that kind of
cry and I just never enjoyed it I hate
crying I don't like it
why would we use it's a happy credit
yeah I just don't like it oh I don't
know I can't really you don't feel like
it's therapeutic though no like because
I don't want to cry either I no one
wants to cry for sad reason so that's a
terrible feeling but it's like but
crying in itself I feel like in my mind
it's it's rain washing down away it's
like the dirt and the grease on the
roads and stuff and I feel like crying
it's kind of like that if you can cry
for a happy reason it's like you're
shedding off like whatever weight is on
your chest you know no for me I feel
like I have a heavier weight on my chest
is it like I'm going on yourself like
you got to let it go but you're so
embarrassed I don't know no I I feel
like her so when I watch a show and I'm
I've seen people crying is all emotional
and then I cry because of what's going
on and when I'm crying I'm just like
[ __ ] dude I don't want to cry right now
and I start getting mad and I start
getting angry I get pissed off like why
the [ __ ] is happening so I'm not
satisfied from it you know so brother
cry from sadness then happiness that's
bad [ __ ] crazy
that's weird yeah cuz for me like I said
it feels like it's added weight on my
chest really I feel like I just got done
with church and my whole that was a
great you know whatever and I'm just
like I'm ready to explore the world now
yeah I'm weird I can't I don't know I
can't explain why I never felt that
until your guys's wedding oh my god
we're talking about dinner when you were
thinking every ball yeah and I was like
no this feels awesome especially when
you're talking about me I didn't know I
didn't know like I forget like I take
you guys for granted you know like as we
see each other we see every day and we
don't talk to each other like that like
I really appreciate you because this and
that you know mine oh this is how it
feels like when someone speaks
positively of you what if I got captured
right now I swear have PTSD yes buddy
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]